[Musique]
au zoo de san diego en californie deux
gorilles ont été testés positifs au
corona virus et sont désormais placés en
quarantaine
oui exactement ce sont les premiers cas
connus de transmission de lakovic et des
gorilles et un troisième primates
présentent également des symptômes pour
moi les gorille respecte la quarantaine
d'heures pour ne pas perdre le contrôle
de l'épidémie le gouvernement envisage
de mettre en place de nouvelles
restrictions
trois options sont sur la table la plus
probable
un couvre-feu à 18h élargi à tout le
territoire
le premier ministre estime que les
chiffres actuels de l'épidémie laissent
penser que cette mesure est suffisante
selon nos informations l'autre piste
sauver celle de confinement locaux ou
partielle uniquement le week end par
exemple si la fermeture des écoles est
écartée celle des commerces dits non
essentielles pourraient être discutées
en tout cas pour l'heure pas de
confinement nationale envisagée on a
déjà des villes des régions des
départements où on a mis le couvre-feu à
18 heures exemple du côté de la meurthe
et moselle où on retrouve séverine qui
est infirmière bonjour séverine bonjour
séverine bonjour c'est vrai une adrine
séverine ce qui vous arrive vous étiez
où s'est vrillé où étiez-vous sur
twitter le ministère de la culture fait
la promotion d'un étonnant serveur vocal
oui on est tous en manque de culture
alors le ministère a déniché une
initiative
le service svp pour serveur vocal
poétique alors au lieu de 8 du ministère
vous composer un numéro de téléphone à
l'autre bout du fil une voix vous
accueille et vous propose d'écouter un
poème ambiance de fou bienvenue sur lbp
le serveur vocal tôt et cliquer pour
écouter un poème taper un chiffre entre
0 et 9 la semoy respirer et longtemps
longtemps
l'odeur de tes cheveux plongé tout mon
visage comme un homme altéré dans l'eau
d'une source et les agités avec ma main
comme un mouchoir odorant pour secouer
des souvenirs dans l'air bon bah ça sort
gagner ça redonne un peu d'espoir non
mais alors ne vous réjouissez pas trop
vite parce que malgré cette campagne de
vaccination l' oms l'organisation
mondiale de la santé prévient que
l'immunité collective de la planète faso
coronavirus ne sera pas atteinte en 2021
voilà de quoi doucher nos espoirs
c'est loin
les coûts
pour bernard tout va bien tg une alerte
vient d'ailleurs tu disais tout à
l'heure c'était les alertes pour les cas
et puis il ya des ce qu'on appelle la
leyre poivrot juste à côté de mon orteil
mec
je vais trouver nous faire charrier avec
sa branche hummer iannone mal barré
bonjour à tous je m'appelle où j'aime
paris j'ai 25 ans je crois que c'est la
première fois que tu veux faire
courtiser par un [ __ ] laveur
du coup un [ __ ] laveur ckoi [ __ ]
laveur en fait le rêve la berge pas je
filme cette semaine c'est moi ouais
c'est super bien que ceci motive et
j'espère qu'elle a fait ça ducation du
pdj m tandis qu'ils descendent dans les
guêtres
alors on demande les hommes peuvent-ils
aussi être atteint d'une descente
d'organes d'après la puce alors les
hommes n'ont pas on soit pour l'abc
puisqu'ils n'ont pas de vagins en fait
c'est l'otage
ah oui voilà si vous pouviez changer de
sexe qu'elle serait la première chose
que vous feriez je sus serait liée aux
caennais s'est passé très vite en charge
25 accords non à tuer dit qu'il te
laisserai le succès au regard de tous
ces petits bonhommes à la queue leu leu
crie pas
quand tu te mets à mettre les sergents à
la queue leu leu
j'ai l'impression d'avoir perdu pour la
stratosphère en plus tard train de
rigoler un maniaque
j'avais l'impression de voir une
gendarmette plus les revanches brimer
pour le carnaval de rio complètement
perché et gtz et c'était bien ensemble
tu sais associés et porter des tenues en
fonction de ta morphologie donc c'est
déjà oui ça c'est vrai bonsoir je sais
bien marier les couleurs aux pigeons oui
tout à fait
cette différence à faire onze mondial
est fini si elle est encore en travaux
c'est difficile de pouvoir à dire ce
qu'on est vraiment sur le coeur du
ballon mais marie bernadette dans une
piscine à boules
ouais et vous savez ce que représente
cette piscine à boules non mon vaisseau
sanguin
enfin un mais vaisseau est un peu gros
mais vous savez ce que c'est que ces
petites boules blanches non
ceux du sucre elle est vraiment vraiment
magnifique j'adore ses formes j'adore la
forme de son visage
un bonbon mais vraiment un bonbon avec
elle c'est sûr j'ai diabète commencé par
prendre ce petit croissant maintenant et
ma foi très bon le problème c'est qu'il
est un peu plein de sucres comprendre
les arcs sucre il arrive un peu
n'importe où y compris sur la tête ou un
plat j'ai vraiment perdu mais que les
toitures des leçons vous avez pas j'ai
perdu mes coups
[Applaudissements]
des bruits résonne de l'autre côté de
l'étang ce bûcheron d'un genre
particulier ne coupe pas du bois depuis
deux ans julien s'adonnent à ce rituel
je casse la glace afin de pouvoir
m'immerger dans l'eau pour me sortir en
connexion avec la nature mais les bonnes
voiles et fraîche on s'est bien amusés
pendant sa lune de miel à la barbade
aucun montage dans cette vidéo filmé par
sa femme ou la tête semble détaché du
corps juste la réfraction de la lumière
le même phénomène que l'on observe avec
un crayon dans un verre mais à une
échelle beaucoup plus grande
tunis
missionné en italie cet accent cette
année
les bonheurs oui
sayonara n'est ce pas sinon
[Applaudissements]
bayonne